before the video starts guys check out
our sponsors Nature's Blends they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic Health supplements and also
from the Sunnah the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code salam10 for 10 of
their products can I ask you a question
can I ask you a question you can forward
filming
of somebody who gets papers smashing
windows and then you have the guy who
sells Windows yeah they both benefit of
each other you smash the window we'll
sell it will give you a little profit
Tommy and Isis are bodies they love each
other I'm being honest with you when an
attack happens I genuinely believe Tommy
gets happy I believe he says that's what
we need because in order for us to
achieve our agenda okay
[Music]
it's just not correct like it's it's
what we're talking about isn't correct
[Applause]
here for about 20 minutes now and we
don't have any updates on specifically
what's happened but what we do know
based on all the reports is that a car
has plowed through Westminster bridge
and crashed into the houses of
Parliament gunshots have been fired
within the gates and three people have
been confirmed dead I don't think this
is any surprise to anybody watching this
it's already reported that the man who
did this was of Asian origin which I
don't think is very surprising to
anybody
if you import a culture you get a
culture this is a culture of violence
destruction and terrorism and there
should be no surprise when we see it on
our streets we're following them waiting
for them to do this
[Music]
[Music]
yeah no problem so no just into uh are
parked and I thought the stage was there
so I was waiting for you there you know
what made me remember because I was like
wait when those when they when they
encircled us you know was it what they
called the swedigans
what made me remember where the stage
was was when I got chased when the job
was getting hit and they took me around
the stage and you see these barriers
here
that's what made me remember okay this
is where the stage is it's not there
because because I was surrounded by them
I thought I was gonna die basically so
that's that's the case I made him
remember I find that quite uh
interesting that was like
it was like a massive
so what like what happened behind the
scenes I mean I guess you know
everything but that was like the moment
everything fell apart
like what did you like I felt like we
were like legitimate that day like I
felt like we'd like to take another
country yeah
like we
popular music there was young people
there what did you think about that did
you think that was like worrying or do
you think it wouldn't last long to be
honest when I heard that this rally is
happening and I knew that for example
this whole freedom of speech thing is
being uh it's it's not the real face of
it I said to myself okay it's a freedom
of speech event okay so that means it's
for everybody so I said surely though
I'm sure they will let me speak yeah
honestly in my head I was thinking I
don't think they are but let's put it to
the test because the way we would do is
it would kind of grow my respect a
little bit so Tommy so I thought you
know what she lives in freedom of speech
I'm sure he would allow me to talk on
stage so that's why I got in contact
with I think Lucio George or you I can't
remember
yeah and then I said look can I come you
know and then I think there was a bit of
it she was like uh yeah I think she she
kind of felt the idea of okay actually
why not kind of stuff so she was like
yeah I said okay good let me know when
yeah so then I was speaking abuse
organizer George and Lucy so I was like
that's quite interesting so I spoke to
each other I said look they actually let
me speak yeah and obviously was like nah
they're not going to I was like why did
it yeah and it seems quite official so
when that happened then we heard like a
back and forth happening you know uh
he's gonna speak he's not going to speak
then the followers return the Robins in
the far right uh they were having the
best I can hear in the discussions I
could on Facebook social media no he's
not going to speak he's going to speak
swap okay what's going on you know I
understood yes some people might dislike
the fact that I'm gonna come but I said
surely if you're standing on the
principles of freedom of speech
you might not like it but you know
you're going to allow me to speak there
was a philosopher who said um
he said I despise what you say about
defend to death the right for you to say
it we quoted that as well yeah yeah yeah
no yeah but I was like I remember when
you were invited when you made the offer
we were in a room with Tommy always when
we were like in a hotel room we were
like oh my god
Tommy Burris started laughing and he was
like that would be serious let's do it
and then Lucy was like he might be
heckled a bit but it'll get going and he
was like
[Music]
[Music]
freedom of expression and freedom of
speech that's literally what it's about
nothing else yeah
um
and he was like I can't do it I can't do
it like it's gonna [ __ ] piss everyone
off I can't do it and then Lucy came on
super super heated she said everyone
knows about this everyone already knows
he's invited he said he doesn't care if
you can spin it up and she said just
admit it it's because he's [ __ ]
muslim isn't it yeah and he said yeah it
is
that's it and that's when we realized
like at that moment that he didn't give
a [ __ ] about freedom of speech obviously
yeah no but we were quite convinced like
I um
like we were genuinely like this is we
are like a cool Counter Culture thing
you know there's a lot of far-right
idiots that we don't want but we
genuinely believed in that and when he
said no that's when it all goes but if
you expose the whole thing yeah no to be
honest look I I didn't have the
intention my intentions was if they let
me speak I've got a speech that I'm
gonna rip tummy into pieces yeah and I
might have a few I just had to work on
my reflexes
gonna be thrown at me but I just okay if
they do that at least my respectful grow
for them because they don't like me
despise and like what I said the
statement of Defending Your Right to
death to speed I thought they would when
he didn't I think he made the biggest
mistake of his life and it truly showed
me what his nature is it's not about
freedom speech that day I knew it you
know because at any day if I came here
to fight or cause an issue I would be at
fault but I was invited I was officially
invited yeah because I'm not going to
come here like you know so when I came
in what I want to do is come in and I
could see there was a conflict someone
was like Oh no you're not speaking today
I was invited okay let's go find out and
I was not even on purpose I I personally
believe Tommy even didn't put us
backstage even he could have put me
backstage it and say okay look you're
not speaking about at least you're
secure he knew the uh whatever they're
called here uh the Football Alliance
they were out there yeah so he kept me
and hijab out there knowing look every
two seconds I had to look behind me yeah
because I don't know who's gonna come
and do what and then what happened is
obviously Jeff got into a bit of a thing
with that other guy the tour guide and
he made a phone call when he made a
phone call I had to get one guy to say
go and call the police because he's
making a phone call I don't know what's
going to happen so when he rang about
five minutes later and we saw oh you
know all those people coming behind us
trying to push us badge us and I was
like look this is what you stand for
freedom of speeches and let me speak
yeah if you didn't if you don't want me
to speak then why'd you invite me here
for so it seemed like a setup to me like
Tommy knew he's not going to let me
speak but he thought there's going to be
atmosphere of hate you know this might
be an opportunity to get him bad
um and yeah and it got fired on him and
he backfired him really badly made him
you know really bad yeah what do you
think would have happened if he would
have let you speak but it was a big
success
do you think he'd be like a massive
success look should I tell you something
if he did that it would have worked in
favor of him that it would have been he
would have said you know what look the
freedom of speech for everyone even
somebody that I don't like I despise I
allowed him to speak it would have been
it would have been brilliant for him you
know but it shows you that the hatred
that he has for Islam and Muslims
contradicts his whole belief of freaking
speech because this is why I say to him
you talking about freedom speech I know
it's nonsense it's absolutely rubbish
because you hate Islam and Muslim so
much that you will go against your own
principles the fact that you're here
standing here shows me that you're a man
of principles you you said look this is
my principles anybody that goes against
it I'm going to speak out against it you
know and we have a principle in the
Quran Allah tells us speak the truth
even if it's against yourself or your
kindness so meaning I'm not going to
speak let's say if you're in the job at
a dispute and I know hijab is wrong I'm
not going to take a job aside because
he's Muslim I'm not going to take this
side because he's my best friend I'm
gonna take your side because he's wrong
and today what you're doing here today
shows me you kind of implementing what
God tells us to do in the Quran how do
you feel coming here like
yeah obviously it's
like yeah it just brings about memories
it brings up memories like I said to you
before I thought the stage was back
there then I said to myself hold on a
second when I was being chased and when
the job was being attacked and the group
of people were chasing me I was brought
to a these black Gates and that's not
there so I said no it must be further up
so the fact that we got attacked helped
me find the stage because that's that's
what made me remember the stadium is
here not there so me and I can't
remember waiting there and I said oh no
actually those blankets are not here so
the fact that we got attacked kind of
helped me in a positive way to find the
stage here today how did you feel about
me
I felt like a bit like like with you I
had a perception about you because I can
remember when was it the London Bridge
attacks happened yeah I can remember use
um I was following you guys on social
media to know like where you guys are so
I can confront you guys you know because
what you were saying wasn't what my
religion was about you know so I I can
remember I came when the attacks
happened in London Bridge
um I think he was then I think we missed
you by it okay yeah he was there so I I
can remember I had a perception about
you you know that you know you seemed
you didn't seem like you fitted in the
photo like you seemed like somebody had
you know been told certain things and
you had hate inside you but you just
didn't seem like I couldn't say okay
this guy I couldn't call you far right
like it's just the words that you were
uttering was but when I looked at you as
a person and you know I was like you
know there's something more to it but
Tommy yes even Lucy I feel a bit like
that about her as well but you know I
just seemed like somebody who's been
brainwashed somebody who's seen certain
things that are happening and rightly so
you know at the end of the day you've
seen people that claim you know shout in
the name of my religion uh coming and
being attacked you know I know that
people are hurt they're upset and they
have a right steps I was upset because
this person is religion but I saw
somebody who was deeply hurt and was
being brainwashed so he was in the wrong
crowd telling you the wrong things and I
really wanted to have a discussion with
you and sit down and speak with you so I
missed you at that moment in time but
obviously I had that perception I felt
you know what actually you know the the
the the the the innocent person that I
saw in you that day was like okay now
he's not that instant because they would
have let me speak you know Lucy came and
obviously when they surrounded us she
was trying to defend us Etc I I I
admired that yeah can I ask you a
question did I ask you a question you
can't over filming if it's an important
question
what I see today in the world regarding
Islam yeah there's no judgment on people
whoever we come from we would love one
another especially as a Christian yeah
but when I see Islam today and for the
I'm 74 years old now Europe you know 45
45 yes
God bless you but uh all I see from
Islam and I've been observing it now for
the past 40 years I became a Christian
about 40 years ago I started building an
interesting religious movements in the
world all I have seen from Islam in the
past 40 years that I have been watching
is violence murder
Slaughter
Mayhem
poverty that's all I see I don't I see
the Sunni hating the Shia I see the Shia
hitting the Chile I see the wahibis
hitting the Sunni it's sorry the Shia
all hating one another that's all we see
murder I used to think a lot of the time
that's I mean I assume you've seen that
in media and not sort of in real life is
that this is real life yeah but there's
a lot of stuff that's
push more in certain ways I mean you
know conflict the media likes conflict
so that's just a denial of what's
actually happening
and Iraq Iran War there was over one
million Muslims killed one another
that's a big can I say something
yeah Uncle you know Uncle you know yeah
the rock around war that was that was a
battle between Shia and Sunni no it
wasn't Uncle can I say something I've
been listening to you and you've
repeated the word I see see yeah yeah so
can I ask television that's exactly my
point because you just keep saying I see
and I was wondering if you went and saw
it for yourself or you was shown it I've
Got Friends who've come from Muslim
countries told me about the Christian
friends I became Christians yes and no
one became Christians they're under the
threat of death I I would say this is
the biggest propaganda out there oh
that's nonsense
well that's nonsense you're not you're
not you're telling a lie this is a
reality
right now they are killing one and Yemen
they're killing one another God bless
you I love you I'm not against you I'm
just saying to you as a human being what
all I see from Islam is slaughtered
if you've made a point if you would the
thing is you've come here if you imagine
if you're a Christian if I came and said
the IRA the law is resistant the
Crusaders and akima said thank you very
much and I want to go would it be fair
for me to come and make these
accusations and then say I have to go
now I have to go now I have to go you
have to go you have to go I'm just
saying I've seen as a Christian that's
all I see and you know I have been
attacked by Muslims in this country for
preaching the gospel
I just met a woman today who was
attacked with a muslim with a hammer she
had I I said a skull
do you mind reading this this is from
the Quran
15 years can I read it for you sure nine
it says when the sacred months are over
take the Infidel captive and slay them
and and who are they who the people who
persecuted Muhammad infidels okay
you be careful young man something be
careful I say that in love I love you
I'm not against you I'm going to be
honest this is thank you is not a
religion of Peace it's a religion of war
and Slaughter thank you Muhammad was a
jihadist and he was the first jihadist
thank you sir God bless you [ __ ]
yourself so so what happened right there
this is actually profound you see right
there what's happened is a perception
that's built in the mind he came and
told us it he didn't want to clarify and
he said I this is exactly the problem do
you see that was actually amazing I
don't believe in coincidence everything
happens for a reason you see that man he
came here
says a few things yeah imagine if a BBC
or someone was recording you're gonna
have people watching me that yes that's
what he's talking about I wanted to
clarify yeah exactly do you see what I'm
saying this would have been Tommy would
have loved this this would have been
beautiful yes yes that's exactly right
exactly the weather's the weather's
perfect the conditions are perfect it
would have been amazing but you see the
moment where I said to him can we just
read this Quran verse I don't want to
know what does that show you it shows
you that he said I'm happy believing
what I'm believing and I do not want to
know any don't tell me anything that may
change my mind however with yourself you
broke that barrier you said no no I want
I want to learn I want to understand and
that's why where you are today is where
you are today
myself personally my father hates me I
speak to my dad my dad says the thing
that I hate the most has been born into
my family but I say to my dad dad just
read that's what I did before I came to
Islam I read I didn't take media so I
just want to be diverse in the Quran
here Allah says in the Quran Allah does
not forbid you as regard to those who
did not fight you
based on your faith and did not expel
you from your homes that you do good to
them and do justice with them so Allah
seeing people that did not come and kick
you from your houses and persecuted you
because you're a Muslim he does not
forbid you from being just and kind to
them so everything that he's seen But
Quran tells me to be just and kind to
the Christians to Jews anybody as long
as you're not attacking me based on my
faith and him quoting Surah October is
talking about the prophet peace be
coming when he was attacked by the Pagan
Arabs his family his uh followers were
persecuted so he's saying basically
to defend yourself you're a Jihadi so as
Muslims what do we need to do we need to
be cut we need this current being
slaughtered and let's find example man
this is
yeah I mean
yeah you know what I like you should say
here because I'm super um or do you like
to have any input I completely like yeah
yeah look how are you feeling right now
just cut it down
um maybe he saw his old self there yeah
I know I did I did see my old self yeah
it's exactly the quotes and the stuff
that I used to say yeah yeah but
is
sad that Islam is a religion of violence
that he said that whatever you think of
Islam you think of terrorism rape murder
villaging that is the core of what we
used to believe yeah with Lauren
Southern with our documentaries with
everything
it's weird I haven't heard anything like
it in a long time and it's just yeah
it does yeah that's that's the reason
you know I don't think you know if you
remember you said that when so one last
point the um the weirdest thing was he's
just like a normal person it's not yeah
so yeah like it reminds me how yeah but
but you see you see like if we go back
to Nazi Germany when the Nuremberg laws
were implemented you see when you want
to slaughter a group of people it
doesn't start with hey pick up the guns
and we're ready to kill nobody will do
that nobody in their right mind will do
that it's all justifying okay why do we
need to get rid of these people for a
better future for our kids look this
religion is bad these people are not bad
but they're brainwashed so what it does
is
it justifies so when you start the
propaganda and the media if you look at
how the Jews were treated in Nazi
Germany where they were drawn pictures
with their big noses evil looking people
you know what they were doing is they
were Preparing People psychologically
and mentally so when the day comes to
pull the trigger they are ready to do it
and this is exactly what's happening
with this man he could justify to
himself and say I like the for example
the Christchurch yeah he justified to
himself and said these guys are the
problem I need to deal with the problem
so he went out there and started
shooting and killing innocent men women
and children why because he justified it
to himself
he didn't if he didn't believe this and
where did this come from he had a
connection to that guy um
you know the guy turned on somebody's
speech out Martin yes exactly and he was
even giving money towards them yeah so
why why is that happening because these
words that we deem to be freedom of
speech it's basically a free ticket to
spew the nonsense that I want to do and
then Tommy's not going to do it because
Tommy lives in a nice house and imagine
he's got a Jacuzzi he'll be sipping his
tea while he's got his foot soldiers
people like you I'm telling you same
goes with magic no us do you think
imagine it was if you believe blowing
yourself up goes Paradise go and do it
yourself in a desert somewhere else and
blow yourself up yeah okay if you
believe go look if you believe in
Paradise instead of getting these
youngsters that you're brainwashing to
go and do your dirty job while you're
sitting on your comfy home you go and do
it that's the reason why we confront
hate from both sides because they're
both I believe they're both business
partners they work with each other you
have somebody who just paid for smashing
windows and then you have who sells
Windows yeah they both benefit of each
other you smash the window we'll sell it
will give you a little profit Tommy and
Isis are bodies they love each other I'm
being honest with you when an attack
happens I genuinely believe Tommy gets
happy I believe he says that's what we
need because in order for us to achieve
our agenda okay
if a terror attack happens like it helps
good
it's good like for example
it makes people angry it makes
more simplified it usually causes a
muscle Spike abuse exactly and and Isis
they they love the same thing with Isis
when an attack happens Christchurch see
what they're doing to our brothers and
sisters in around 1 million you see what
they're doing time will take revenge
that's exactly itself for the answers
it's emotional most of these youngsters
who carry out the London Bridge attacks
what is that I speak to them I've
confronted some of them their ideology
and their thinking is by they do it to
our brothers and sisters I say to them
okay
sisters is Bush my teacher or the
prophet Muhammad who's our teacher Bush
or Tony Blair or the prophet Muhammed
Prophet Muhammad will the prophet peace
be upon him going through innocent
people no so don't give me false
analogies of 20 players not my teacher
another look at Tony blame them include
a million people okay let me go do the
same this not my teacher Islam is what I
live my life by and it doesn't teach
that and what you said I know it